so my view is that you know India is
growing at a very fast pace it's
attracting the global interest to a
large extent but at the foundation level
you know we've seen many many millions
of people moving out of villages into
they come into what they are safe havens
in the cities are which are slums then
they are rising up that slums are very
good at throwing people out they love
the basic techniques they get sensitized
and then they move up the value chain
and these sums have also as cities an
organization is developing in India
these cities are actually moving you
know these were villages which were then
you know the land was bought out by a
lot of people around them for
construction purposes the villagers
moved out to further locations these
slums became houses for the you know
workers and then today you see house
tiles village which is born up the chain
to become a boutique
so you can see how the transformation
has happened but the underlying how do
they continue to do this is
unequivocally education there's no doubt
I know everybody talks about it I'm very
passionate about education myself and
I'm a large contributor to setting up a
educational institution in Mumbai but
we've got to work through various levels
and you know why are people talking of
education at the primary level the issue
there is you're ending up in a situation
where you people drop out right the
reason is how do you incentivize people
to come to your class is to make sure
that they get who because if your kids
children's are not you know you know
pull up and we know as children when
you're not full up you can't concentrate
it on learning so I think food security
to make sure incentivize children that
they can't get breakfast get breakfast
in school who can't get lunches get that
and get a nice package to go back in the
night so that they can eat they will be
more than well incentivize and never
give up because that's the first thing
you do and once you keep doing that you
get this foundation layer which is
healthy and they're in their energies
are used in the right fashion to drive
the economy forward so that's what I
would call inclusive growth and then you
go at the top we're producing some of
the best engineers doctors PhDs
scientists how can we take them to
become of a global scale India with its
growth is also attracting a lot of these
people from where's you know from the US
from UK and all of that brain is power
is coming into India so I think a
combination with the bottom arm and a
reverse migration of intelligent people
with education being the foundation is
going to be critical of course if we are
well-educated will be then be able to
make good use of the resources which are
scarce whether its food whether its
water whether its energy and we need the
government of course at the final level
to really keep doing what they do best
which is focus on infrastructure
development